c'est la saison du vêlage quand il ne
donne pas le biberon aux agneaux moussa
sissoko aide des brebis à mettre bas
sous le regard de son maître
d'apprentissage
dans ses traits et au milieu de ce
troupeau le jeune apprenti ouvrier
agricole de 19 ans goûte à la félicite
c'est un moment où de plaisir où
j'aimerais bien en faire de ça toute ma
vie quoi je me sens
comme toi on va faire un métier qu'on
aime beaucoup reconnaît mme clicquot
comme ça on pourra pas tenu et au fait
mais qu'est ce que ça vous procure du
bonheur
difficile d'imaginer à cet instant
précis sont passés cabossé jeunes
mineurs non accompagnés
arrivés clandestinement du mali il a
saison et les rêves plein la tête
devenir agriculteur éleveur
puis à commencer par faire un capa
métiers de l'agriculture de deux ans qui
a obtenu et là il en première année de
bp responsable d'exploitation agricole
il s'est débrouillé tout seul pour
trouver sa formation il s'est vu très
beau nier tout seul pour trouver son
maître d'apprentissage
ce qui est plutôt rare ils ont veut il
savait déjà se projeter ce qu'il sait il
a déjà son parcours en tête moussa
sissoko va se rendre au salon de
l'agriculture
il est candidat au concours des jeunes
berges une marche de plus sur son
parcours il ya quarante participants y
en a deux par région alors forcément
nous n'est pas dans une région la région
centre val de loire c'est pas une région
était très dense en terme de moutons du
coup forcément ça va être liver un
certain niveau mais je pense que nous on
sentait comme ça comme il était
passionné par l'élevage de moutons on
on pensait que c'était intéressant de
lui proposer ça pour son développement
personnel à moussa sissoko a trouvé en
arrêt noir sa terre promise et sa corne
d'abondance il caresse un dernier rêve
reparti romani et devenir agriculteurs
éleveurs maraîchers